new images tonight buried bodies of dogs  found in amargosa valley as nye county  officials and forensic investigators  with the aspca continue their  investigation in that animal cruelty  case we are told the dogs were in  various stages of decomposition two  people have been arrested and charged in  the case  and a look now at some of the smallest  victims of that animal cruelty case  these are posted on the nye county  sheriff's facebook page you can see  animal shelter staff in the aspca  working together to help these puppies  recover now if you wish to donate to  their efforts there's a gofundme link  you'll find that over at  eightnewsnow.com